- Hi, everyone, welcome to
the homeroom livestream.
Sal here from Khan Academy.
So we're gonna have a
disappointing guest today,
it is myself.
So we're gonna be doing
an ask me anything.
So if you have questions
about literally anything,
I hope to be surprised by
your questions within bounds,
put them on the message boards
or wherever you're watching this,
whether it's Facebook, YouTube,
or maybe someplace else.
But before we jump into
the ask me anything,
I'll give my standard announcement.
First of all, reminder that Khan Academy
is a non profit organization.
We can only exist through donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please go to khanacademy.org/donate.
I also wanna give a special shout out
to several organizations that
have supported Khan Academy,
especially through this COVID crisis.
There's many others, more the name,
you go to our supporters page,
but especially as we're
going into the COVID crisis,
we were already running at a deficit
and you could imagine our
expenses have only gone up
with our server costs and
us trying to accelerate
a whole series of content and programs
so special, thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, fastly, Novartis and
many others who over the years
have supported Khan Academy.
Many of y'all, without that support,
it wouldn't be possible.
And we are continuing to run at a deficit
especially for next year
so please think about
making a donation.
Everything makes a difference.
So with that, I'm excited
to answer questions.
And so the team has already started
surfacing some questions.
I think a few of these
might've been from before.
So let's see, these are
all really good questions.
So the first question from
YouTube, Vivek the Sai
how do we level the playing
field in low funded schools?
It's a good question, you know,
I think arguably Khan Academy with the
mission of free world-class
education for anyone anywhere
it's implicit that we are trying
to level the playing field,
especially for folks who are low income,
or might be attending
schools with less resources,
or maybe don't even
have access to schools.
And so one theory of
action for us is that,
you know, hopefully folks will be able to
leverage things like Khan Academy
and start as students
using it on their own,
but you know, half of our usages teachers
using Khan Academy as
part of their classrooms,
where students are able to
work on Khan Academy exercises,
sometimes aligned to the
student teacher's lessons.
Sometimes the teachers
,students are doing it their
own time and pace.
And teachers are able to then understand
where all of their kids are and
then support them more
inside of the classroom.
We've seen a lot of efficacy studies
that can make a huge difference.
Now, clearly, in order to use Khan Academy
that way there's some prerequisite things
that have to exist internet connections ,
for sure at the school
devices at the school,
ideally it would be at
the home and school.
we're seeing that a lot with COVID.
But you know this is
one area that we think
we can help level start help
leveling the playing field.
I don't wanna pretend like
it's a simple solution
and that you can just snap your fingers
and that everything is perfect.
Some of y'all know, I have
another skunk work project.
It is not a part of Khan Academy ,
it's actually incorporating
it as we speak as a
separate non-for-profit
called schoolhouse.world
to try to get more folks
access to tutoring as well.
So that, you know, not only
can you get all the practice,
the feedback, the video supports
the instructional supports,
the teacher supports through Khan Academy,
but you can also become, you
know, connect to other people
and really become part of
a community of learning
is really my dream.
Because in both of those cases,
learning is not bound by time or space,
learning can meet you where you are
and then, you know the
zip code that you live in
or the income of your family
or the neighborhoods you
live in should matter less.
Unfortunately it always
probably play a factor,
but it will hopefully matter a lot less.
See, there's a question
see Jim Sugar Brown
from Facebook asks ,
Sal, how do you see the future
of education and learning?
Can you differentiate between the two?
So that's a big question,
I like that you're trying,
you know, you're saying, well,
the different education and learning,
you know when I at
least imagine education,
I imagined all of the things
that the education system does,
there's a learning component of it
and we're traditionally thinking of like
core academic skills then
there is a socialization,
you know, a lot of us, we
learned to kinda of work
with others in many years of school.
And then another thing
that the school system does
is kinda of a credentialing aspect to it.
I think we're learning with
COVID also the school system,
especially for younger kids
provides a childcare function,
but it's, it's really
academics, credentialing,
socialization and kinda of care of kids.
And there's other supports
that the education system
does as well things like lunch programs
and other social supports.
You know, the learning you
could think its broader
it's a lot of that,
but you could, you know what
when I imagine learning,
I imagine, you know,
me using YouTube to figure
out how to fix my toilet,
which I've done several times
especially during COVID or,
you know, just learning
how to play guitar.
And arguably some of these
things could be part of
the education system as well.
But I think in either case,
we're gonna be moving
to a world where there's
gonna be far more paths
that people can take,
and they're gonna be far more customizable
to the needs of the individual.
And as these, as the
paths that you can take,
become more personalized and more diverse,
then there's gonna be more universal ways
of proving what you know,
creating a signal to you know,
you could call it a credential
so that other people
can understand what you are capable of.
I also think you're
going to see, you know,
I've I talked about the
schoolhouse.world project,
which is separate from Khan Academy,
but I also think you're
gonna see more mechanisms
where communities of people
are going to be able to
support each other and kind
of a very grassroots way
which I think could be a
very powerful, you know,
I think historically the last 200 years,
education and learning has
been a very centralized affair.
It's it's been, you know,
a couple of folks get
together in a room, I mean,
famously the courses that
you, many of you all learned,
or we all learned in high
school were determined
by 10 university presidents in 1890
and then there's the community
of 10 you can look it up.
And so that's obviously
a centralized as it gets.
So I think you're gonna start
seeing a lot more diversity
and paths but you're gonna
start seeing much stronger ways
that you can prove what you know
and really community being a
very powerful way to learn.
So there's from YouTube,
Smart Bear asking,
Sal, can you tell me
how did you make it to
where you are right now,
founder and CEO of Khan Academy.
I oftentimes wonder that myself.
Oh you know, I think growing up,
I think we all have this kinda angst
and frankly, the angst
hasn't gone away yet
that you know, we have one life,
how do we make it count
or how do we make it worth something?
And you know, we can debate
what it means to count
or what it means to want something.
I believe that I've
evolved over over time,
you know, when I was a teenager
or in my early twenties,
I think, you know, I imagined counting,
making a dent in the universe,
being all about kind of external,
whatever impact external, you know,
whether it's discover a new
drug that could cure a disease
or impacting people in a
certain way, or, you know,
I'd have to admit especially
early in probably even now,
but early in my life, I probably
was motivated to saying,
hey, I would like to be able to, you know,
I grew up not so wealthy
and back you know, my mom I
think made $16,000 in 1994,
which was a year that I had
to help her fill out the taxes
to get financial aid for college.
So we didn't have a
lot of money, you know,
she was making roughly minimum wage
so there was in me, a lot of,
I would say a fire in my belly
to try to be financially comfortable
and not have to kinda
go through some of the
financial uncertainties
that we had growing up.
And anyway , so I did what I
thought would make sense there,
but I never like was
just one of these kids
that it was just like, okay,
what do I need to do to get a job?
You know, what's gonna be on the test?
Let me just ace it, I naturally, I mean,
I think y'all can tell
my personality no matter
how pragmatic I try to be my,
I do a lot of daydreaming.
My personality tends to wander into the
I don't know what you would
call it, the aspirational,
the delusional, the imagining
what the world could be.
And I've often felt this
angst that like, you know,
we only have so many
decades on this planet
let's make it interesting.
You know, let's not just try to,
let's just not try to
go through the mold that
everyone else has.
There's certain things
we have to do to be able
to pay the bills and you know,
hopefully get a house and pay
off your debts, et cetera,
et cetera, support your family.
But, you know, we got let's
make it interesting too.
So anyway, you know, college
I tried to do my best that,
you know, to kinda get a
good job at had a good job,
you know ,in 1998 came out
here to Silicon Valley,
worked at Oracle as a product manager.
It was a good job had a really good boss
and he was Thomas Kurian.
He's actually quite
known in tech circles now
he runs all of Google Cloud,
but I was one of the first
people he ever hired.
He was in his early thirties at the time.
And then, you know, it was
startup, it was the.com mania.
I went joined a startup
that was a great experience.
But then, you know, the
NASDAQ started to tank
and I said, actually I
should take some shelter
in business school and
try to figure out what
I wanna do with my life.
I also say, you know, I
went to business school
because I was lonely and I had
this theory that in Boston,
there were a lot more students
and I could probably find,
you know, a life partner.
So I went back to Boston
for this goes true
both things happen i
figured out what I at least
what I wanna do career
wise for my next stage.
And I met my now actually
I met my wife back in 1997
and you know, I had always aspired
to get to know her better for many years.
And but then in 2002, I got,
I was successful and she
hasn't figured it out just yet
that, you know, I've
definitely been the winner
on this situation.
But the anyway, I'm probably
going into more of my biography
than you're asking, but,
you know it was kind of,
it's been like this kind
of a very securest path,
but it was I think many of y'all
know, you could find videos
on YouTube and other places of me telling
the Khan Academy Genesis
story, but it was really 2004.
I was a analyst at a hedge
fund cousin needed help
and but in the back of my mind,
I had always thought about that
you know, maybe technology
could be a really powerful tool
to scalable help a lot of folks.
And so that's when I
started tutoring cousin's
word spread that free
tutoring was going on.
Then I started tutoring more cousins.
I started making software
for them, videos for them,
people who are not my
cousins like yourselves,
we're starting to use them by 2009.
I had trouble focusing on my
day job, 2000 so I quit it.
We were living off of
savings that was scary
I mean, you know, you're
asking, how do I get here?
You know yeah, you're
gonna have these moments
of having to kinda jump into scary things.
And you're gonna question yourself
and you're gonna, you know that year
that Khan Academy had no funding
and I was living off of savings ,
our first child had been born,
it was creating all sorts of stresses.
I was waking up in the middle
of the night, you know,
what had done to my family?
Would had I had done to my career?
So you're gonna have your
moments of self doubt,
but then, you know, it's
been we've intricate funding
and we've been on this
journey and you know
and even now I have my moments
where I'm super excited
I'm like, wow, we're gonna
be in a position one day to
impact billions of folks.
But then there's days where
I feel that, you know,
something went wrong or, you know,
I thought we were gonna get some funding
for some big project and it doesn't happen
or you know we were
trying to build something
and we realized that you know,
there's, there's mold in
the attic so to speak,
and it's gonna take more
work than we expected,
but you try to power through those things
cause you know, it's I
consider myself very fortunate
to be able to work on a mission like this
and to be able to work with
really great people, you know,
the Khan Academy teams of
200 folks now we've had
thousands of volunteers
so it's, you know, it's,
if you get to work on something that's
intellectually interesting
can make a dent in the world
and you're able to work with
other really good people
you know, I don't think you can really ask
for more than that.
So, you know, I hope to be able to do this
until the day I die, which
is hopefully, hopefully
many decades from now.
So Rude Ranell Mudhal from
Facebook if you were not
in this profession, what other
profession would you go for?
So, you know, some of,
if I'm honest, you know,
before this, I was an
analyst at a hedge fund,
so maybe I would still be
an analyst at a hedge fund.
Although even while I was
an analyst at a hedge fund
and I know some of you are
wondering what is a hedge fund.
A hedge fund is essentially an
investment management company
think of a mutual fund.
The definition of a mutual
fund and a hedge fund
is a mutual fund is heavily regulated
but because it's heavily regulated,
they're allowed to market more broadly,
but they're essentially
mutual funds buy stocks,
a basket of stocks and you know,
you're using your money and
if it does well, it does well,
hedge funds also are buying
or selling a basket of things,
but they're less regulated
so they can buy other things.
They can buy auctions ,they can buy debt,
they can buy they could
even buy, you know,
they could buy literally
literally anything
and they can do more exotic
things like, you know,
futures or they could short things
or you know, have options.
So, I was already in that industry
there's definitely I
would have stayed in it,
but I used to tell my
friends, my rationalization,
I did enjoy that work.
It was very intellectually
stimulating and it paid well.
I said, I would do this until I could be
kind of do whatever I wanted
and then I would start a school one day.
So I did always have these dreams
but obviously the school
happened in a different way
through Khan Academy
it happened well before
I was able to do it
able to do it on my own.
You know, I think in
alternate realities, you know,
I would, I probably could have maybe been
a science fiction author
that I'd like to believe that
who knows anyway, who knows,
but I probably would have
stayed in the hedge fund world
and then eventually
transitioned to becoming
some type of an educator I think.
So from YouTube Akshay Murphy is asking ,
what type of global impact
could Khan Academy have
and why does my school
not use Khan Academy?
Is there a way to make Khan
Academy more widespread?
Well, actually you're
asking three questions
that I'm constantly asking myself
and the team at Khan Academy
we're constantly asking
ourselves what kind of
global impact can we have?
Why isn't that school using Khan Academy?
And is there a way to
make it more widespread?
You know, the global impact
we could have you know,
we have over a 100 million
registered users now
we have about a 30 million
folks come to the site
every month and do some
type of a learning action.
It's a smaller subset of
that is doing it at like
a very regular rate.
But obviously there's 100 millions,
arguably billions of students in the world
who could benefit from Khan Academy
and there's 46 translation projects
going on of Khan Academy.
So, you know, my genuine dream is if
we're talking five, 10 years from now
that let's say 10 years from now,
there's billions of folks
who are using Khan Academy,
it's their lifeline to get
practice, to get feedback,
to learn a lot of things.
Ideally they're able to use it
in conjunction with schools.
It's able to unlock a kind
of true personalization
in a school setting,
teachers jobs get easier.
They can use that data
they don't have to like,
you know, assign things and grade things
and all of that can happen automatically
and they get really good data so that when
they get together with students they're
able to dig a little bit
deeper, motivate them,
unstick them, do projects,
do simulations, et cetera.
And I hope, you know, because
it's at a scale of billions,
we're able to, you know, move the dial
on whatever you wanna call it.
Impact scores, test scores,
outcomes on the scale of nations
or on the scale of internationally
so that, you know, in
10, 20 years people like,
could you imagine there used
to be a day where 70% of folks
had to take remedial math in college
or this large chunk of
humanity thought that
algebra was difficult now
everyone knows how to do it
it's like, you know,
it's just a basic skill
that all of humanity has.
And I don't think, you know and we're not,
our vision is not just
to stop at math you know,
we already have a lot of
science and social sciences
and humanities on Khan Academy.
I think math is where we're strongest now
probably followed by science
and we're actually hoping
to actually accelerate a lot
of the science over the next few years
but eventually we want to cover
all core academic subjects
everyone where fit create
ways for people to prove
what they know to the broader world.
So it's a big vision, you know,
why is your school not using it?
I don't know so I think there's
gonna be a video version
of this you should, you
know, Akshay school,
please use Khan Academy we'll wanna make
life easier for you.
And we think your kids will enjoy it ,
your teachers will enjoy.
We're here to support all of you teachers.
So Akshay school think about it.
And then how do we make
it more widespread?
I think we just have, you
know, on Khan Academy side,
we just have to make
sure we understand the
needs of teachers and keep
improving on the, software,
the content for them, the use cases
so we can support more and
more of what they're doing.
And then we just have to work with
all of y'all in the world
and corporations whoever
else to spread the word.
You know, I think a
lot of people are like,
they don't fully understand that one,
we're not for profit ,we're
not selling anything.
Everything we're doing is
philanthropically supported
and free.
So and it's frankly the most
efficacious thing out there.
Some people think that
if something is free,
it must not be as good
as the expensive thing.
But if you know, do your research,
if you look at efficacy
data, if you look at,
if you just talk to people
who've used Khan Academy
versus other tools, I think
know this is one of those worlds
where I I'd like to believe
that the best things
in the world truly are free
so help us spread the word.
So there, so from YouTube
Pression Bow is asking
is kinda go primarily for homeschooling
or just for practice?
Well, it can be used for
either of those things.
We know a lot of home
schoolers around the world
lean quite heavily on Khan Academy,
especially for math and science,
but in other subjects as well
and things like our SAT
prep which goes to math,
reading and writing, we
have Khan Academy kids,
which is math, social, emotional learning,
reading, and writing, but it's
not just for homeschooling,
it can be used for practice
in fact that's where we've put
most of our resources to have
kind of a practice platform
where you can get especially in math
and we're starting to have in science
and other subjects as much
practice as you need on all the
core skills with game
mechanics that make sure you
retain it that you can
really master the content.
But we also have video supports and hints
and articles that so you're not just doing
that practice in a vacuum.
If you're having difficulty,
you get more supports
and if you're doing in a
classroom context, your teachers,
or actually it could even be your parents
could be your coach can
understand what more help you need
so that you don't get stuck
with just the supports
that we're able to provide like the video.
So, we'd like to see
it as all of the above.
From YouTube Maheka Toprani
hey, Sal, you always talk about
how you had a huge passion for
learning, even as a student,
have you along the path of
your education ever strayed
from this passion ?
How did you deal with such slumps?
You know, I've, I've always, I've never,
I guess not been curious.
I've never like had a
moment where I'm like, Oh,
learning's no fun ,i
don't wanna understand
this mystery called life,
no, I've never been there
I've never been there.
I have been in places where
I've been demoralized ,
feeling insecure, wondering
whether like everything
I've ever done has been pointless.
I've definitely had those moments
and I've definitely had
moments where I'm just stressed
about something.
Is something's gonna turn
out the way I want it to be?
Or you know I'm working with a colleague
or I have a manager or
boss where I'm like, Oh,
I don't think they understand what I did
or I don't think they like me
or you know, we all go
through emotions like that.
The way that I deal with the
what you could call slumps
is I remind myself, you know,
once you have a little bit
of a hindsight of all your past slumps
and I gotta believe Maheka
you have your slumps,
you've had your slumps
and if you look back on
your slumps, you know,
some of these things that in the day that
you were completely stressed
about it, you're like, Oh,
it's the end of the world i
can't believe this happened.
and someone said this or whatever,
this is gonna happen
oftentimes a week later,
like you even forget what that thing was.
And even if something is
something more serious,
it has longer lasting
implications you know,
I remind ourselves we have
a finite number of years
on this planet.
This planet is a spec in
this broad universe you know,
even these things that we
identify very, very strongly with,
you know, I identify very very strongly
with the name Sal Khan I
identify very strongly with
this, you know, appearance with my role
and with my family, with society,
my job with Khan Academy
usually all things that
I identify very strongly with you know,
my ego and like, you
know, the technical ego,
not the like braggadocios ego,
but like my identity, ego, persona,
whatever you wanna call it,
it is connected to all of these things
and the times where you
often feel the most stress
is when you feel that some
aspect of your persona,
some aspect of your identity
is under threat you know,
my identity, I think I'm an honest person.
Why does that person
think that I'm not honest?
Or, you know, I think I did a good job.
I think I'm capable,
but maybe someone else doesn't
think so, or, you know,
my persona is tied to the
success of Khan Academy,
but wow I just got a data
point that maybe Khan Academy
is gonna have trouble in
that area that causes stress.
And the way I get through
that is one reminding myself
that a lot of these things
resolve on their own,
usually for the best,
but even if it resolves in a negative way
to not tie my who I am my
identity to that outcome
cause that's not gonna benefit anyone.
That's just gonna make me miserable.
It's not gonna change
the outcome, you know,
in Eastern philosophy
and Vedic philosophy,
there's this notion of South wick action,
which is do what you think is right
but don't get caught up in the outcome .
Don't do something because
you think it's gonna
have a great outcome,
or because you're afraid
that if you don't do it,
you're gonna have a negative outcome.
Do it because you think
it's because you think it's
the right thing to do and then
the chips fall where they do.
And if you do that it's
actually very very liberating.
You do what you think is right,
but you won't obsess about it
you won't regret things as much
and you'll just be a happier person
and you'll just be more open
to kind of just, you know,
positive things out there.
Another thing I'd recommend,
I've talked about this before
is I do a lot of meditation
and you know, I think the
benefit of meditation,
which is really just sitting quietly
and giving your mind a chance
to steal itself you know,
most of us, our minds
are constantly jumping
it's like a circus in
there you're like, Oh,
I gotta pay my taxes, am
I watering my lawn enough?
You know, do I need to,
you know, do my laundry,
I wonder if I'm gonna be
able to fundraise enough
for that effort on Khan Academy,
is that team not aligned?
I need to talk to this person you know,
we have this constant
narrative in our heads
and sometimes it's just like
completely random stuff.
Like if a bear attacked
me, what would I do?
It's, there's all sorts
of stuff that is going on,
at least in my mind when you meditate,
you kind of say, okay, self,
give yourself a chance to just pause.
Don't be worried about
what's happened in the past
or what's in the future
just be in the present
and just let your mind
just be an awareness
don't think about, I am
Sal don't think about,
I hope Khan Academy succeeds
don't think about what people think of you
or all of the chores you have to do
just be there aware and
at first it's difficult,
but once you start doing it regularly,
you'll actually find that
it's an incredibly peaceful
and it's incredibly liberating
and it kinda stays with
you the rest of the day,
where if something happens
that would traditionally have
triggered you or make you
feel off, off balance,
you'll be like, you know what?
This is just happening
in material reality.
This isn't really affecting my true self.
So, you know, you do what's right.
If you have to correct something,
if you have to say something, say it,
but then don't get caught up in it
but anyway I give you a longer,
I kinda ended up giving
you kinda of a whole
life philosophy lesson, a ticket for it.
And look, I don't wanna
pretend like I'm in like
a permanent state of
Zen or Nirvana either.
I have my moments, but my
coping mechanism is definitely
to kind of get more grounded, centered,
not fixate too much on my persona
and realize that most of
the stuff resolves itself
and we have only so much
time on this planet.
Let's not spend that time obsessing
or feeling low about
ourselves if we can avoid it.
I know there's many cases
where it's much harder
and if it's in a tough situation,
definitely seek help because, you know,
that's the other thing I would say
if you're in a really bad situation
or even a medium bad situation,
cause sometimes it's worse
than you might realize find help.
No don't be afraid to ask for help
or embarrassed so from
Facebook, Selena Chang,
what are some problems in the world
that high school students can help solve
by creating their own initiatives?
Well, so, you know, I gotta say there's an
and time goes by fast
when you're giving advice.
So, there's a ton that
you could do right now.
I, you know, there's never
been more opportunities
for people, your age outlets
to help the world you know,
we're living in a world and you know,
there's a lot of positives
and there's a lot of
negatives people talk about,
things like social media
and YouTube and all of that.
But there's a lot of positives as well
like you can create content
that can help teach people,
you can create content
that builds awareness,
you could create software
that helps solve real problems
for folks, you know, in this COVID world,
it surfaced all sorts of new problems
but the other side of
the problem coin is that
these are opportunities for
things that need to be fixed.
You know, I talked early
in the COVID crisis
about creating mechanisms to help elderly
in your neighborhood.
Like get the things they
need so that they don't
have to be exposed.
There can be mechanisms, you know,
everyone is rethinking
about how they do everything
right now, from how they
get their groceries,
to how you know, what
they do for entertainment,
to how they stay connected
with friends and family
these are all huge opportunities.
I've always said, you know,
people focus on so many
things that the day to day,
but they often don't
focus on some of the most
important things like the
memories of their family
and all of that.
I've wanted to start a project
that I haven't had time for.
I've been trying to convince
every young person I can talk
to start it i would be a
customer if you started this
of doing really
comprehensive interviews and
documenting the life narratives
of essentially everyone
in my extended family.
Cause how powerful would that be?
You know, I had an uncle
who passed away recently
and you know, I kick myself
that I didn't, you know,
sit down with him for a few days
and just record like every little detail
about his life history,
one to help remember him
but also those stories are gonna get lost.
And if you think about it, those stories,
those memories are the most valuable thing
that my family has but no
one's thinking about that.
And I wanna do that with, you know,
I wish I did it with that uncle.
I wanna do it with his wife,
I wanna do with my mom.
I wanna do it with everybody you know,
the, my wife's two of her
grandparents are still alive,
I tell her every day, like
we gotta get them on zoom
and record their life story.
You know, one day we're
just gonna kick ourselves
for not doing it.
But I could imagine a service
that does something like that.
Kinda like what, you
know, StoryCorps and NPR,
but on, on steroids so it can like,
it can document your entire
family I would pay for that.
I think that would be more
valuable than anything else
that I could do.
So anyway, that's just a, there's a lot
that could be worked on right now.
And maybe at some point we
could have an AMA where we
brainstorm either not for
profit or business ideas.
So I'll end on that looks
like we're almost out of time.
Let me see i will I'm gonna
answer one more question,
just cause it's a good one.
I mean, there's a lot
of good questions here.
I have about two more minutes
from YouTube Jadgid Said is asking
I was always told about my grades
decide my future is success
without good grades possible?
I think saying your
grades decide your future
is a strong statement,
I think grades might influence your future
and they definitely good
grades can open up opportunity
and not so good grades,
unfortunately can sometimes
close opportunities.
That's why I've been a big
fan of mastery learning
because in mastery learning,
essentially your grade is never permanent.
You can always improve yourself
if you're at a C level today,
that just means you haven't
learned it fully yet
you can get to a B or an A.
So definitely have that mindset
I would say early in your life,
your actual grades are more
feedback for you and your family.
So if you're, you know, in
elementary and middle school,
what really matters that you
eventually really mastered
the material so that when
you get to high school
and college which, you know,
I wish they were mastery learning as well
or were more mastery learning,
but that's where the stakes unfortunately,
in today's world get a little bit higher,
but I've seen time and time
again, there's many folks,
you know, don't be down on yourself.
If you're making your
best effort, you know,
it'll go back to that South wick action.
If you're taking the
action, you're saying,
look, I'm doing what I think I need to do
to the best of my ability
i'm making the effort,
I'm stepping out of my comfort zone,
I'm willing to try things that seem
a little bit difficult for me,
but stick at them.
Then the chips fall
where they do, you know,
the grades are what they are.
And then, you know, what I've
seen is there are folks where,
you know, the grades can
bring the opportunity,
but there's also folks with great grades,
but you know, they, they
don't know what to do with it
or the life kinda throws
them off balance one way
or the other and that's tough.
and I know folks with, you
know, not so great grades,
who've done incredible things.
So definitely don't think that your grades
determine your destiny.
And definitely don't let that
be a source of being down
on yourself, because then it becomes
a self fulfilling prophecy.
If your grades, if you're
doing your best effort
and then you're still not
getting the grades you want
and then you think that that
says something about yourself,
it's gonna affect your self esteem,
which is just going to become
a self fulfilling prophecy,
where you're gonna be less confident.
If anything, the people that I've seen
most successful in life are people
who have invested themselves
making sure they have some
set of really valuable skills,
people who and they are willing
to kinda put themselves out
there into the world and
sometimes fail, you know,
sometimes be embarrassed
sometimes to be told no,
to sometimes be rejected,
but they're constantly
developing themselves
they're constantly putting
themselves out in the world
and they, you know, we
all have our low points.
I have my low points, but
you know you're able to
kinda pick yourself up from them
and hopefully put you know
and fight the next battle.
I think puts you in a pretty good position
regardless of what your grades are.
So anyway, I'll leave y'all there,
take everything I say
with a grain of salt.
I am not like a paid like anything
well, for in terms of advice.
So, you know, but hopefully, it's helpful,
but these are really great questions.
Thanks everyone.
And I think it's next week ,
let me see it's gonna
be Thursday actually,
we're gonna have Jeff Rosen
who I consider a good friend
from the National Constitution Center.
It is a constitution day.
So we're gonna talk about the
United States constitution,
which has also always and I'm
not saying this sarcastically,
I actually generally mean
it because I love learning.
It is actually an amazing
thing to talk about.
Cause we talk about it
in popular culture a lot,
but when you actually read it
and I encourage everyone
to read it and digest it,
it's quite readable I think it's,
it's a very powerful document.
So anyway, I look forward to
seeing you all on Thursday,
as we talk about the us constitution.
(logo chiming)